i've been like so embarrassed
by the american the lack of american
arrogance lately yeah when we were
growing up there was a healthy arrogance
yes i remember i went and studied abroad
in spain okay
and i might be on the higher spectrum of
like arrogance sometimes right right no
maybe a tiny maybe just a little bit
tournament uh wedding was in montecito
not santa barbara but just to clarify
yeah
it's fancy you know what i mean how
would i know you know me and my gift
weren't invited i know yeah yeah when we
renew the vows okay okay um
i i showed up wearing [ __ ] cowboy hat
i'm from new york cowboy hat like a
american flag shirt some blue [ __ ]
adidas pants yeah like
in vance i was like screaming america
and i was like you're lucky i'm [ __ ]
here right for a year to study abroad
and i was talking to ronnie chang about
this the other day he's like yeah like i
think america's been humbled you know
like by the news by the experience
what's going on and like because
americans are very like uh uh polite
abroad now right we go oh of apologizing
before we go into places et cetera now
there's no we should be
polite i don't think that we should be
polite but i think that there's a lack
of [ __ ] confidence going on in
america right now yeah and
this is where i understand why people
feed
i don't want to say [ __ ] but that
why we feed [ __ ] why we feed these
narratives and stories and create
heroism out of things that might not be
that heroic because low-key don't you
want a more confident people if you have
to be part of something right wouldn't
it be a winning story like i was asking
this english a person the other day they
were just in the audience i was like yo
do they tell you that the empire's over
like do they teach that yeah at all and
they're like no
they don't even know they're people in
england that don't even know that they
don't run the world and if you look at
them and you see everyone in the world
speaks english they're probably going
yeah we still run it some some of them
are some of them do know
i think it really depends right like the
american arrogance is alive in certain
places
it's just we're on the decline right now
you can feel it and we got to turn it
around yes we got to turn it around but
we're on the decline you can feel it
have we ever been in the decline
historically in this empire the american
empire and then turned it around because
i think my fear is how do you turn it
around is there any stopping china there
no you could listen there are the roles
there's ways to turn it around but as of
right now
um
we are i think
without argument we're we're on we're on
it downwards slow okay i i'm gonna push
back on that i don't think that that
slope is as steep as you presented
um
maybe not because right now the war is
culture right and i mean like
we're not going to war war with china
everybody dies right and our culture is
still more influential than theirs we're
not walking around chinese
yeah you know what i'm saying they are
adopting american culture the war is
economic though the war is more than
culture culture is a fake war the war is
economic and their economy is really
growing at a bigger pace and ours is
there's more people yeah more people
more engineers
there's a guy uh from where he used to
work raytheon or something like that
that came to the show uh in oxnard right
and he was just saying like they have
superiority in terms of weapons he goes
weapons don't matter because we can all
kill each other they can just kill us a
little bit quicker i'm not worried i'm
not worried about even
i think china's a problem i think the
threats to the american
project were internal hold on i want to
get to that one second but what he
specifically said is here's the the the
reason why we could potentially lose
they're just five to one that's five to
one engineers that's five to one like
[ __ ] dancers for tick tock it's five
to
one also culturally promoting
engineering like in america people want
to be youtubers they want to be famous
they want to be this you want to do that
sorry we don't necessarily have the math
and science core and the value system
yeah i mean there's a reason why all the
kids and the new spider-man go to mit
right their whole life is about how do i
get to mit i think for example he loses
all his friends yeah just so they can go
to mit right it's how do we get these
[ __ ] kids here's what happens when
you start learning again you know i
remember when detroit remember when
detroit like fell none of us remember
that detroit you don't remember that you
don't remember that you don't remember
that you remember detroit fell yeah
detroit as a city like went bankrupt
you don't remember this yeah where were
you it was like in high school yeah it
was kwame kilpatrick right yeah it was
like a pretty big story yeah yeah yeah
but then detroit been following robocop
was detroit yeah yeah she's actually
been on fire since the 80s yeah that's
the problem do you see what i mean when
you let american cities just completely
disintegrate
and there's like five cities where
everyone has lamborghinis and then the
rest of them are on fire yeah that's a
problem and what happens is is your
country begins to decline
whether you can see it or feel it
because you're a millionaire and all
your friends are millionaires but the
reality is if you go to these other
places where people don't have jobs you
don't have health care they're totally
[ __ ] they don't see a way out their
kids are on fentanyl their daughter's
not only fans this is part of now when
those people but industry changes
certain people okay sure that's well no
this is american history industry is
going to change cities is going to make
certain cities more economically viable
than others i understand that but when
you look at that that working class
when they had jobs and could go on
vacations yeah and they had money yeah
and they weren't being completely uh
replaced and their jobs weren't you know
being shipped overseas yeah you had a
more robust country you had a you had a
better
sections of the country so those
sections yeah buffalo at one time
rochester at one time were more robust
but don't you see that as a so is west
virginia but don't you think that's a
problem no i think this is the nature of
changing an industry but that's where
the arrogance that you're missing is
miami it's hard to be aggregated when
you live in a tent but if you can but if
you can see the rise and fall of cities
how do you not see the rising fall of
countries that's what i mean like you
don't think eventually this is like if
the rise of cities is natural and that's
the evolution no i understand i
understand what you're saying i guess
what i'm saying is it's it's not as if
there a new city isn't also going to pop
up so if rochester and buffalo falls
yeah another place is probably going to
pop up but it's bigger than just
specific cities these are entire
industries we have no manufacturing in
the country right this is a bigger
problem we have no manufacturer we don't
make anything here yeah everything so if
you're an unskilled worker and you don't
have any skills yes you're competing
against immigrants that come in all the
time you're competing against your other
uh you know neighbors and friends and
you're competing against people that
live overseas that are willing to do the
jobs for cheaper so i'm just saying
listen i'm not an economist but i'm just
saying when you talk about arrogance it
like where's the sense of american mojo
and where did it go a lot of it is like
[ __ ] you drive 20 minutes out of
any city yeah you're driving to a third
world country and when you drive through
a third world country when you drive
through parts of cleveland and they look
like sarajevo well they look like
yeah okay that's a problem this is no no
this i this i agree with it's an issue
no this i agree with i just thought you
were supposed to push back in that
specific city like crumbling doesn't
mean another won't pop up and that is
something for sure that's naturally
gonna happen in the course of a country
yeah but when you just have these
sacrifice zones whatever it is no go
like you have these areas you're like
and they're popping up all over the
place then you have tent cities yeah
should be like you talk about the
american like you're driving around you
look you go oh it's yeah you can't
everywhere feel like the greatest
country in the world if you're seeing
all
extreme
time
and i think that's affecting people's
senses
and also there's probably this sense
because of social media like remember
back in the day when you live and
existed within your neighborhood you
understood how wealthy or poor you were
within the proximity of the people that
lived with you yeah and now we're
constantly faced with all these people
who are doing so much better than us
even if they're not really right they
look like they are on the internet right
so there's probably an ego hit that
comes from that as well you're like oh
[ __ ] i thought i was successful i just
started making a hundred thousand
dollars a year and you hop on instagram
and there's some 19 year old that just
made two billion dollars questionably
there's an interesting okay
okay fair enough okay i i agree with
that you're constantly confronted with
everything you're doing wrong and we're
doing a lot of uh self-reflection as a
country right which you don't see a
country like china doing like china's
not sitting back and going oh hey how
were we bad 300 years ago how are we bad
200 years ago and how can we be better
now
the the concern is that we would just go
well let's forget about all the [ __ ]
up things that we did in the past we
don't want to do that right we want to
know what we did we don't want to ignore
our history right but
i and i'm curious about the people who
are like orchestrating america for the
next like 200 years as they figure out
like what we learn in schools are they
sitting there and they going hey we need
to instant instill some heroism man like
we need to make people feel proud of
america because right now we're making
people realize all the [ __ ] horrible
[ __ ] they did yeah and we're not
comparing america as a country to other
countries we're only comparing her to
herself and that's where you start to be
embarrassed yeah i think there's a real
fight
and there's a real
tension between those two views
and i don't think it's going to be
resolved anytime soon i think there's
people that believe that
the job of
schools
is to
tell children
why things are the way they are
which is
what i think a lot of the proponents
of
some of the newer critical race theory
and stuff like that
are doing they're saying
here is a theory that explains why it is
and then there are people that go that's
not the job for school the job of a
school is to give you the facts the
figures tell you 10 theories 10 reasons
why things may be the way they are and
have you
come to those conclusions on your own
yeah we don't need to force feed you
that one particular theory we need to
provide now there are also people on the
far end of that spectrum who go well we
don't like we want to only show the
pro-america theories we don't want to
show the critical
uh race theories we don't want to show
how
incarceration might be related to racism
slavery or racism or any of that there
are people that go that theory should be
banned and then there are people go we
should only teach that theory and i'm in
the middle that goes teach all of the
theories yeah and let the kids
um who are on fentanyl anyway and aren't
listening
uh let them figure out what theories
they are going with i don't think
schools should ever go this is the way
and the only i try to look at like the
best case scenario for
for both sides right i look at the best
case scenario for the critical race
theory side right
not the person that's that's trying to
sit there be like white people are bad
here's why the person who's literally
trying to explain to some kids hey this
is why there might be a discrepancy of
wealth and opportunity absolutely like
when you look at your friend who doesn't
have the things that you have like now
you don't have to think that you know
he's just unlucky maybe there's
circumstances that put him there and
then maybe you have more empathy like
that's what i think best case scenario
for the critical race there and i think
that's that's great i support that right
and then i think best case scenario for
the people who don't want to teach it
right what if they're literally going yo
what if we stop teaching these kids that
they're different from one another what
if they'll start treating each other as
if they're the same maybe that's best
and maybe it's naive to think that no
but maybe that's because i can probably
write about what the best case on each
side wants and like
and i like your strategy about teaching
both of them but i'm like man it would
be [ __ ] nice
if you were curating these stories that
americans could feel [ __ ] proud of it
give me a top gun movie again like give
me something that we're doing that's
good that we should feel proud of not
[ __ ] dance challenges on the internet
i'm talking about some real americana
[ __ ] get our [ __ ] balls back and
start walking around with our [ __ ]
head straight up man yeah it's it's
and i wonder what you do that through do
you do that through school
like do you do that through kids i think
you do it through
a mixture of a bunch of things policy
culture
you know you you give people you need
like a springsteen bro
you need like a new spring
like here's the deal i don't think that
works anymore i i don't think that works
no i don't think it works anymore why
well i think we're just i don't think
we're a country at this point to be
honest can i tell you another reason i
truly don't believe we're a country at
this at this moment
i would say there's more i could make a
better argument i was a debater
i could make a better argument that we
are a collection
of of of nation states or whatever than
an actual country at this particular
moment you want to know something and i
want to hear i want to hear your your
actually you say what you were going to
say first of all new media is why i
don't think it works everything's too
splintered when it was springsteen in
the 70s you have like three different
options for programming and it's all
pretty easy to be the same so
pro-america really easy to get behind
now there's a pro-america guy there's a
thousand [ __ ] america guys singing a
song on spotify that's one playlist over
so i don't think it works as well but
let me ask you a question i'm sorry to
interrupt you but based on what you just
said i have a friend who said this about
india indian guy but i think it might
also apply to america should we just go
to an eu model
where the country is it's a
i don't think we should do that but i
will tell you this
the reason i would say effectively we're
not not that we're not a country but
effectively
you got to look at
what's good for certain people is really
not good for other people in this
country we've reached a point where
you're the right for what you want to do
and how you want to live
is not necessarily good for me and it
used to be where we would have
differences but then we had these
concentric circles it would overlap and
our interests were in the middle and a
lot of our interests lied was like okay
they're keeping us safe from the soviet
union or this or that or whatever but
now
you know if you are
the country was designed with that in
mind though like yes but it was also
designed with
that's the states rights idea right so
for sure i live in virginia you live in
maine i'm not gonna but the idea that
that one state goes we're heart we're
very pro-gun yeah and another state goes
we don't want guns at all great and then
you go okay but the problem is people
are buying guns in one state yeah and
using them in another state so
yeah right the reason why this is tricky
is because back in the day it took six
months to get from maine to virginia
that's right now
yeah success two hours right right
whatever it is exactly so
so now you have to have more uniform
laws yeah because now there are people
that go we want tracking
and there are people that go i want
uh yo your fracking is coming down our
river and then yeah causing people to
die in our state where we make it
illegal we're too interconnected to to
have such different rules and laws is
that what you're trying to say i mean
we're very interconnected and but we're
also at the same time dude our lives
aren't any in anywhere
like
my life being good yeah and somebody
else's life being good may depend on
things being diametrically opposed like
different so uh i think you're
developing a caste system
yeah i think that's what you're kind of
talking about well it's kind of
happening right already you already have
it happening yeah like we we dismiss
knowingly or unknowingly yeah we dismiss
the people who live in troy yeah because
we don't work in factories yeah yeah
yeah and we go hey things happen yeah
cities spring up move to austin start a
podcast yeah itself yeah yeah but the
reality is those people want to kill us
because they go [ __ ] you
you guys are benefiting from buying this
hoodie yeah for no money yeah because it
was made like and there's always going
to be some level of that tension but
it's just gotten to a point now where it
does feel like it's bubbling over
here into something crazy and here's the
thing it's
if you're in one of these places that's
not considering troy at all right right
it doesn't even pop on your radar right
it's almost like um
how america is with the rest of the
world like we don't consider like what
sweden does but sweden needs to consider
what we do that's right right and i
think we often treat
cities towns etc within america
with that same
for lack of a better word arrogance
right right and
that does become a problem especially
when those people are resenting i was i
was on stage the other day and i and i i
just asked the people in the crowd who
the new mayor was this is right when
adams got elected right
what percentage do you think could say
the name of the mayor in their town half
not even
10 yeah is generous wow now your life is
so good right
you can remove yourself from politics
that's right totally those people up in
troy they can't that politician is make
or break yeah
people like that living in the same
place that is what you're talking about
that's what i'm talking about that it's
just it's interesting right and it's not
even it's not even me like having a view
or how to fix it or political it's just
me looking at everything and going [ __ ]
this is a pickle what what is the uh the
french queen uh let them eat cakes marie
antoinette it's let them eat cake bro
it's kind of that and then oh they're
struggling to troy let them eat cake and
then people get angry and then it
becomes a capital riot it becomes antifa
it becomes like violence on the street
and some of those are just rich kids
larping that's fine but like what you
see is it becomes opioid crisis it
becomes i have i'm in despair i don't
have a future i don't believe my life is
going to be good and it's so funny even
the drugs that you see people using now
like uh like ketamine is
because what are they
they're disassociation yeah they're
giving me everything is get me out of
here everything is escape it used to be
like life is fun i want it to be even
more fun right i want to have energy for
the whole night full of right right and
now it's i don't even want to deal with
this yeah i don't want to deal with
[ __ ] whatever white guilt i don't
want to deal with whatever these [ __ ]
things are ketamine k-hole i'm out don't
talk to me i'm not yeah you even see
some of these [ __ ] rich kids doing
heroin again right when we were younger
that was like
so [ __ ] taboo because they they also
have no purpose yeah they're tapping out
of this because we've gotten rid of
religion we've gotten rid of you know
you don't feel
uh you don't have a community anymore
everything's global so you're on
instagram oh i'm talking to somebody in
dubai i'm talking somebody here there's
no communities that are local anymore
and electronic communities build a lot
of things but they're also very
isolating yeah and they also
limit interaction to some degree they
they they make it a lot easier but why
you have so many friends online right
because you don't have to be with them
all that's right
you